Brian.
David.
Congratulations, you've
made it to the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forges where you will recreate
an iconic weapon from history.
That weapon is-- a Knights
Templar Crusader Sword.
Good luck Bladesmiths,
we'll see you in five days.
Good luck, man.
Good luck, Brian.
What I am really stoked about
in building the Knights Templar
Crusader Sword, is the
fact that it's a Knights
Templar Crusader Sword.
It connects with Christianity
and the religious upbringing
that I had, it's
really going to be
rewarding on a lot of levels.
This is the steel I'm going
to use to make my sword.
The dimensions that I'm shooting
for are 36 inches in length
and are under 3 pounds.
I could cut it and forge-weld
it, I could split it,
I could draw it all out, but the
plan is to pull the sword out--
sort of like that.
I have never unfolded
metal this way before
and this is a big
piece of steel.
I think I can work with that.
DAVID: The main thing with
the sword is to remove weight.
So we're going to work
on weight reduction
and get the fuller in there.
Just a quick dirty full
of ground in there, man.
I have to start thinking
about my heatery too.
I'm going to have to hook
a burner up to this forge.
People up in Alaska,
more so than many,
we make a lot of our
own tools and equipment.
But really don't
do this at home.
It's good to take your time.
Make sure that you
have all the clearance
that you need and then you can
get the piece into the tank.
I don't want to rush anything.
Main thing it's got
to get a good heat
treatment, the
abuse that they're
going to put this through.
You can have a disaster
going into the clutch,
I mean, it could
come out all twisted.
We'll just hope that
that doesn't happen.
So far it looks good.
And it's hard.
So we got a
successful heat-treat.
I'm happy.
It's not a live blade, it
just has to be finished up.
Can almost see the light
at the end of the tunnel.
BRIAN: I got some
straightening to do.
It's the beginning of day three.
I've got the
profile established.
There's a little bit
of beef here and there
that needs to come off.
Looking good.
I'm feeling really good
about my blade at this point.
It's to contour,
the follers are cut.
There's only one thing that
I haven't done with my sword
and that's weigh it.
Oh, we are over 3-pounds,
just with the blade.
Anything more than
3-pounds places me
at risk for elimination.
By the time I add a pommal--
5.5.
[beep]
DAVID: This wood that
I'm using right here
is Alaskan Yellow Cedar.
Really nice wood for handles.
I like it, it's really light.
Now I've got to make the pommel.
I've got a long blade out
there, you need something
to counterbalance that.
That's what I was looking for--
a nice piece of wrought
iron, over 100 years old.
Just the right diameter
for the pommel.
That's going to add
weight to the back
and give it some balance.
I can't wait to see how
it feels, right now.
Oh, yeah.
It went very well.
Look at the smile.
Having my celebratory ice cream.
My ice cream cosy.
Tomorrow I just expect to put
the final grind on the blade
and we will be ready
to do some testing.
BRIAN: My blade is almost done.
I drilled my pommel.
I drilled around the
edge of the pommel.
Ground a little bit
on my cross-guard.
I've got my mass down
to around 3-pounds,
but I don't have a
quench on my blade
yet, that has to happen today.
This is holy water from Chalice
Well in Glastonbury, UK.
This is where
Joseph of Arimathea
allegedly hid the Holy Grail.
Not much, enough to--
enough to bless
the piece though.
I'm ready to go and I'm
scared out of my mind, man.
This is a long blade and
if it goes down the toilet,
I will be gutted.
I think we have
a blade, Hoo-yah.
The blade is essentially
done at this point.
So it's time to move on to
the pretty parts, the geegaws,
as I call them.
Inlays from holy trees, to
the handle, red garnet's
into the face of
the pommel, this
will symbolize Christ's blood.
There are four real
religious artifacts
included with this piece, not
to mention my own love for it.
I feel like I want to
slash at something.
This is a kill test.
A Knights Templar sword.
An iconic weapon battle-tested
throughout history.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
we'll take your sword
and deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy.
Brian, you're up first.
I would love to test your
blade, but as you can see,
I'm still recovering
from an injury.
So to be my arm
today, please welcome
RJ Marcaida, my brother.
He will have the pleasure
of wielding your weapons.
[music playing]
Your sword is a little
bit on the heavier side,
but because of the pommel
you have over here,
it actually balances it out.
There are areas that
are sharp and there are
areas that are not as sharp.
On the final blow, that edge
have proven to be very sharp
and actually would disembowel
this ballistics dummy.
Your sword sir, will kill.
All right, David,
it's your turn.
You ready?
- Let's do it
[music playing]
That is one of the sharpest
swords I've ever come across.
It's wicked scary.
The cuts lacerated
it almost in half.
Without a doubt, your
weapon will kill.
Awesome.
WILL: Ben.
Gentlemen to test the strength
and durability of your edges,
I'm going to attack these
fully armored knights.
What this test is
all about, what
the armor does to
your sword, not what
your sword does to the armor.
Brian, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Absolutely.
[music playing]
Looks good.
Well, Brian, your edge
held up really well.
It's a very obtuse
grind that lends
itself to this kind of test.
The handle was comfortable.
It's a nice shape.
I was able to index very well.
It stayed straight in the test
and didn't pick up any damage.
Well done.
Thank you.
David, you're up next.
[music playing]
Well, Dave, you have a
much finer edge on this sword
and it's picked up a
little bit of rolling.
There's some edge deflection
right here, you can hear it.
But all in all, a
very good sword.
Thank you, sir.
All right, gentlemen.
Next up, the swinging
sandbag slice.
I will cut this rope with
one edge of your blade,
releasing that sandbag
and then cutting that
with the other
edge of your blade.
Let's see if they
still have an edge.
Brian, you're up.
Are you ready?
[music playing]
First off, there are sections
of this blade that just
don't have much of an edge.
That first cut just
skated up the rope.
A second cut bit in,
went right through.
You can see how there's a lot of
tearing at the edge of that bag
as opposed to a clean
slice through it.
I would have loved to have
seen a little bit more edge,
especially on that front half.
David, you ready?
Absolutely.
OK.
[music playing]
Your sword is sharp.
Very sharp.
Passed through the
rope, no problem.
bag, no problem.
As far as the design
of your sword,
I would have loved to have
seen a counterbalance on this.
This would be nice on a dagger,
it's very small for this sword.
Without that counterbalance all
that weight is so far forward,
but it's a cutter.
It's definitely sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
completed their deliberation
and they've made
a final decision.
You've both put in
a lot of work here.
But there can only be one
Forged in Fire Champion.
And that champion is--
Dave.
Congratulations, you are
the Forged in Fire Champion.
Brian, unfortunately,
your Crusader Sword
did not make the cut.
Brian, I really applaud the
fact that you brought a lot
of yourself to that sword.
In the end it came down
to your sword just wasn't
as sharp as your competitors.
And that's why we've
got to let you go.
Understood.
Brian, please
surrender your sword.
David's sword cut
better than mine.
He out-smithed me.
That's the way it goes, man.
In the end there
can be only one.
I may make another Knights
Templar Crusader Sword.
I've still got 2,000-year-old
Oak that's at home.
I still have holy water at home.
Anything can happen.
David, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire Champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for how much?
10 grand.
That's right. $10,000.
Good job.
Victory feels good.
In this competition,
it showed me
that I can push myself a little
harder and maybe get more done.
Looking forward to
getting back home.
First thing I'm going to do is
fix my bike and go for a ride.
[music playing]